ich will ihn noch ein beispiel zeigen
heinz buschkowsky aus neukölln aus ihrer
heimat von der straße das beispiel kommt
von freitag dort gab es eine
vergleichsweise kleine polizeieinsatz
ein mann in diesem bmw sitzen sollte
kontrolliert werden und dann kam es
plötzlich zu schießerei auf der straße
wir sehen hier den fahrer der versuch
durch diese straße durchzukommen was von
vornherein schon ziemlich unmöglich
schien steigt dann aus wir haben hier
den polizisten rufen und genau um diese
schreie ging es anschließend im letzten
der nicht etwa über den kriminellen der
dort gejagt wird wurde gesprochen
sondern über den polizisten der nämlich
ganz genau gesagt hat hände hoch du
[ __ ] und das wurde ihm negativ
ausgelegt haben sie dafür verständnis
dass der polizist sich in dieser
angespannten situation so ganz leicht in
der wortwahl vergriffen hat verständnis
für den polizisten ja verständnis dafür
dass man jetzt zutiefst darüber
nachdenkt ob jemand der mit dem auto
versucht einen polizeibeamten um zu
knallen
ob er den als [ __ ] bezeichnen da was
sicherlich kein protokollarischer
begriff ist also das finde ich dann
schon unter der überschrift die wir
vorhin hatten wie gehen wir endlich mit
unseren polizeibeamten um da wird gerade
der versuch gemacht einen polizeibeamten
mit dem auto um zu knallen
ja und wir haben nichts weiter zu tun
als darüber nachzudenken ob er sich
korrekt verbal dazu verhalten hat da
kann ich mich einfach nur noch an den
kopf fassen und das machen denke ich
viele andere normal denkende menschen
auch man muss dazu wissen dass in dieser
gegend wo das passiert ist bereits zwei
polizeibeamte im dienst erschossen
worden sind dass eine andere
funkwagenbesatzung während des dienstes
im funk bahn zusammengeschlagen wurde
das sind da so die verhältnisse mit
denen wir es da zu tun haben aber
wahrscheinlich wird man noch
irgendwelche begründungen
bin warum der polizeibeamte sich nicht
richtig verhalten hat
das sind dinge worüber man in berlin
sich keine gedanken mehr machen darf
weil er kriegt ihr jetzt ich werde da
weil er sich in der wortwahl vergriffen
wird bestimmt eine
dienstaufsichtsbeschwerde kriegen das
andere hat thomas strobl wie absurd ist
dass dass wir nach so einer situation in
der wir alle sehen das ist total
angespannt auf der straße und der
riskiert gerade sein leben dort in
dieser situation anschließend über seine
wortwahl diskutieren ich würde sagen
lasst mal die kirche in kauf aber klar
ist auch dass muss allerdings in berlin
stattfinden das auch so etwas untersucht
werden muss wie das ergebnis dann
aussieht ist eine andere frage
aber so sehr ich hinter und vor unseren
polizistinnen und polizisten stehen
klar ist sie repräsentieren den start
und sie repräsentieren und haben das
gewaltmonopol innen und deswegen sind
auch ganz besondere voraussetzungen an
sie zu stellen dafür haben sie eine
entsprechende ausbildung sie sind in
besonderer art und weise an recht und
gesetz gebunden und auch in stuttgart
gab es in dieser nacht eine bemerkung
durch einen kollegen die kritisiert
worden ist ich finde es im übrigen schon
auch in ordnung dass polizeiliches
handeln in deutschland hinterfragt und
kritisiert wird das macht ja gerade
unsere demokratie aus aber ich würde mal
sagen in einer solchen situation lasst
die kirche im dorf und unsere
polizistinnen und polizisten sind eben
auch nur menschen und gott sei dank
keine roboter